and uh if he only plays two or three
tournaments he needs to be on form in
one of them at least but magnus not
happy no look at that just gesturing
exhaling
he just hasn't gotten the flow he hasn't
got out of the opening with any strong
positions against level iranian
no he hasn't and this one but this one
in all fairness is because lavon
played uh brought a new idea to defend
its pawn and now black's rook can simply
step across and take a pawn
okay there we go
whose
pieces are gonna be more active it looks
like white but the black king is
actually quite well placed now better
than its counterpart
yeah
and uh
too many two little pawns on the board i
think for it to be too dangerous for
either side yeah there is a bit of a
threat in the position white was
threatening to step his pawn forward to
kick away black's bishop but now look at
this magnus carson has activated all of
his pieces to the maximum this is
perfect n-gate technique from the world
champion and we see levon aronian give
up a pawn but it's opposite color
bishops the rooks are off white will
block 8 on the light squares black wall
blockade on the dark squares and the
extra pawn doesn't count it's going to
be a draw
all right a draw meaning levonaronian is
still up by one point it's gonna be a
game four to decide this match magnus
carlsen will have to win that game for
in the rapid portion to take it to tie
breaks a draw or a win for levon and